some interesting posts this morning at the
David Pakman show subreddit, which I encourage
you to check out@davidpakman.com slash R E.
D. D. I T a lot of theory about CNNs handling
of Tuesday nights democratic presidential
debate. The hashtag CNN is trash, uh, has
been trending after the democratic debate.
I am going to dig in later to some of the
specific subtle ways in which CNN manufactured
a particular type of consent, uh, during the
Tuesday night debate.
This is separate from the questions that were
asked. This is separate from who got time.
It's a very specific analysis that I want
to share with you, which we will get to a
little bit later on in the program. But yes,
a lot of people furious. Uh, with CNN and
w what's really funny is I got some tweets
from people saying, David, now you see that
CNN is the Fox news of the left. No. If CNN
were the Fox news of the left, they would
be supporting the more progressive candidates.
That's not what they're doing. They're actually
a stat, a PR PR, a supporting by default establishment
centrist candidates. Another notable post
from a user named future Microsoft guy who
says Biden is worse than Hillary. I pray that
Sanders gains momentum and wins the primary
with Iowa. I feel Biden is a step backwards
from Hillary, although her career is far from
good.
It's a damn angel compared to Biden's four
plus years of this unimaginable, and God knows
if we will continue with Trump's kids. I am
not convinced that Biden is worse than Hillary.
I think they're the same in a lot of ways.
I think there are probably some foreign policy
areas where Biden may actually be a little
more, uh, knowledgeable than Hillary Clinton,
if not markedly better. In terms of his points
of view. I see them as very similar. I see
them as cut from a pretty similar cloth. I'm
not saying that they are the same, but it's
not clear to me that Biden is, is notably
worse than Hillary. Also on the David Pakman
show subreddit. More posts about Trump not
debating potentially Marvel man. Oh two posted
Trump will refuse to debate Bernie if he's
the nominee. I'm making a prediction. If Bernie
is the democratic nominee, Trump will refuse
to debate him.
Of course, Trump will create some dumb excuse,
like the debates are rigged. They're rigged.
I think Elizabeth Warren might have trouble
debating someone that's stupid and Joe Biden
would simply be a repeat of the 2016 debates,
but I think Trump is still canny enough to
understand that the bag of tricks he used
against Hillary won't work against Bernie.
I've been getting more and more emails and
calls and tweets about this. The idea that
if it's Bernie Trump won't debate. I don't
think it's going to come down to, if it's
Bernie Trump won't debate Donald Trump in
mid December, I think it was December 16th
going from memory, put out a bunch of tweets
attacking the commission on presidential debates
saying, I'm the president. I'll decide about
D debates. Maybe I'll do more debates. Maybe
I'll do fewer. Maybe I'll do none. Maybe I'll
do different debates than the ones organized
by the commission on presidential debates,
but basically making the point that he'll
do whatever the hell he wants.
We know his supporters will defend what he
does no matter what it is. So I do think that
it is, it is not outside of the realm of possibility
that Trumbull choose not to debate. I think
if he chooses not to debate, I don't think
it will really do him much damage because
the people who would be swayed by debates
are still going to be able to figure out who
to vote for. Those who would be disgusted
by Trump not debating, are already not voting
for him, and his supporters will just basically
agree with reason Trump gives for not debating
in the first place. So I actually think that
it's, it would not be the stupidest thing,
particularly if Donald Trump's slowness and
sort of confused speech continues to get worse.
It may actually be to his advantage, not to
debate. I don't think he'll suffer for it.
Join the discussion on the David Pakman show
subreddit@davidpakman.com slash. R. E. D.
D. I. T.